[Music]
like pulling a curtain aside by pop up
on it's almost sign wavy with a little
bit of a clip to it to give a little
percussiveness but it's very clear tone
I worked in a game where we tried
everything to do our version of that and
it's really hard function is transition
I wanna go from here to there if you go
really consonant and very catchy where
you can walk down the hall singing it
that's too high there might be too much
of a reward so want to give you a little
bit of something that feels like it's in
the pocket of a musical motif we want a
tease and a gulf that gamer it to keep
going forward
[Music]
that's like a 10-second long clip that
is an eternity in games the camera lusts
over this box filled it up build it up
and spins around build it up and gives
all the time that's needed no pause to
be able to create that level of
anticipation and then the payoff and you
got a map you know short and sweet it's
definitely sort of a Pavlovian response
when you hear it paying homage to the
old Zelda but using a little more modern
sounds often creating something that's
very short is much harder than creating
something long and having it tell a
story that level of subtlety in sound
choice at Blizzard would be completely
tested internally in an alpha stage
sometimes you have to pull from sounds
that you purchase and license from some
people and then you record stuff as well
combine those together to create new
interesting sounds let's go with a
little medical bliss modernized at this
cool little tackle of sci-fi with it if
the heal went on for five seconds
or it went on for 10 seconds or went on
with for 20 seconds looping was a great
way to do that
boop-boop-boop-boop when it stops stop
the sound and then play the decay of it
[Music]
Tony Hawk's Pro Skater a game that I had
the fortunate privilege to work on its
height a hyper-reality
from your perspective may not sound that
way but who maybe would put a mic at the
bottom of the wheels in my backyard I
had concrete I had stone I had brick and
I don't know how to skateboard I fell
off the skateboard literally hundreds of
times I still have the scar I don't know
if you can see that right there
and so when you fall off the board and
you hear that that's me actually falling
off the board
headaches wooo and they're gonna sit on
our lucky when you record vo for a game
you'll almost always need to localize
that video in other languages so it's e
fix English French Italian German
Spanish the advantages of creating fake
languages anybody in the world complain
the only have the record isn't one
language it definitely has a structure
it seems like it has grammatical rules
Acadians to it they toned the inflection
definitely iconic choice
[Music]
J Wineland I believe made that sound if
I'm not mistaken from Bunji pelo brought
it to the next level not only for video
games and the way that artificial
intelligence reacted within a game but
also from sound and music as well what
expresses really well is that moment of
danger with its cadence the integration
and the implementation and they did
different pitch variations and different
volume variations they knew how
important sound design was this is a
powerup song that's so thing it's really
cool the sweeps that do that and do that
pitch over time I don't want to say it's
cliche now but it was of an age when you
turned the computer on or synthesizer
and you went through this long
complicated startup I think the Taser
was like probably my favorite sound in
that game you taste somebody to go like
it was the reactionary portion of that
that I think is really cool power it has
energy occupies a lot of the low-end
that came from Glenn Stafford and Brian
far added to the actual magical sound
design Twitter he was like it's maybe
neutral to whatever race levels up it's
not something that that a druid would
make or a shame it would make sits on
its own level of study within WoW itself
no wonderful company love the sound team
they're really really imagining so right
and it's so soft on years it just gives
you that level of power there's probably
some sort of element of coursing which
is essentially a modulation effect
that's time-based you know they do a
character named Gladys we were such fans
of that not a Pacific Rim gypsy we based
it off of Gladys and that's interesting
how film was not paid homage to video
games to the sound of a video game
[Music]
so my guess is one of two things slow
down animal mousse or hay crocodile or
slow down vocal it sounds almost like
you're trying to have a human voice
emulate a will when it comes to punches
the important thing is the randomization
two pieces of wood I take a bell
snap it a flat bat back the crap out of
like a hanging rug or a whip and hit
something you get that kind of crack
watermelon bash the out of it like
with a hammer to get the whooshing I
actually shot arrows into a turkey yet
bones and crackle and then I took a
mallet and a frozen turkey and hit it to
replicate the blood and the flesh it's
not unusual for us to either go with a
sound or to put six seven sounds
together to make up one punch this is
one of my favorites I've heard it's like
some guy just going on I got some vocals
on you and they just nailed it their
personalities overlap as little as
possible so they can stand out on their
own so you just want to take one note
and just give it a little trim elation
in the right place that's all you need
that's a sound of a klaxon that's been
recorded or alarm that's been recorded
but it's not a claxton and that's what's
great about it is that it feels like
something you've heard but a same time
for something different
definitely spells impending doom and you
learn to count how many of those things
happen every time it's terrible
to me the most important sound in a
videogame is the footstep sound in the
case of a game like Dragon Age it's what
connects you to the earth it could be
rock they could wood it could be grass
there could be stone carpet there could
be watered you could be flesh there
could be bone not only do you have to
think about the surface maybe you're an
army boots maybe you're in sneakers
maybe you're in high heels building that
level of believability into it that
leads to eight or ten variations
anything that becomes repetitive no
matter how good it is you just go oh god
now it becomes torture if I'm walking
over grass every now and then oh I broke
a twig and part of the strategy is not
to be seen in her you hear footsteps
that means an enemy's coming at you and
you have seconds to react audio is no
longer post-production
you know the sound on minecraft is
simple what an amazing game because it
makes you use your imagination in so
many different ways when you look at my
craft it should never have been made in
modern video games there are so many
sounds
everything has a sound unless you don't
want it to with inside a video game it's
what's called an audio engine thousand
mm sound effects so there's software
that the sound designer uses to put all
of these sounds in different banks it's
not unusual for a gun to have 20 40 50
sounds when you're in a driving game and
you hear your engine sound
and then you go into a tunnel all sudden
the sound changes thousands of 3,000
lines of dialogue it's big it's huge
what we're doing is sound designers is
saying if you're in that tunnel then I'm
going to assign this tunnel reverb and
it's going to do it in real time on the
fly
very cool
in the strategy in eSports if it doesn't
serve a purpose it shouldn't be there
low frequencies they get lost in
everything else so you need something
that pierces through I watched the
international a few years ago
commentators pointed out and they turn
down the sound for ocean sound becomes a
tactical information tool you have your
eyes now your ears so you can create
rhythms but a lot of times eSports very
focused on accomplishing the task and
not dying well that's the merlok
localization it was made by Tracy Bush
that sound was accomplished by Tracy
gargling yogurt probably the most famous
sound come out of Blizzard Entertainment
as far as I'm concerned I remember one
time I didn't believe him at our company
Christmas party it was intended to be a
placeholder sound it took our audience
to tell us that that was the right sound
and so he just gets a glass of water and
goes oh like it was like spot-on people
Clapton oh shut up that's pretty cool I
worked on I think yours war 2 3 and a
whole bunch of variations you recorded
on you can't play back at the volume
that you'd normally hear it of course
there's thousands of different styles of
guns there are many things as animals we
use we've pop a tube if it's a gun where
it shoots out but the casing well you
just you grab casings and you drop them
on the ground one of the things that I
notice is when the nice cars go by you
the extra sonic lasers so I've taken
those and put them on guns so you listen
and you build and that's sculpting now
we have to enhance it now we have two
Hollywood eyes the sound it's not real
you just think it is
I love the sound of those guns
there was definitely a philosophy in the
design of overwatch which we called play
by sound when you're getting towards the
end there's a beep that enforces you
that you're about you know you should be
able to close your eyes and know exactly
what's around you how close danger is
where your teammates are so much to my
right eye here on the right speaker just
I'm flipping to the right I mean there
are people who are legally blind who are
playing the game and playing it
successfully
[Music]
[Applause]
first of all they rent and record
hundreds of cars so what we do in games
we attach the pitch right to the rpm
tires off you put it up thousand rpm
fifteen hour rpm mm and you
remote-control it so if a certain car is
redlining at 9,000 rpms I need to decide
what note value is 9,000 rpms will
record the muffler will record the
intake valve we have mics and the ways
of being able get the rid of the wind is
our science and we've got mics under the
hood and it's doing what the whole
granule is slicing it's taking little
bits of each little cylinder and
rearranging them it's not Hollywood it's
a simulator to be a sound designer
anyway the complexity that goes into
games are no longer simple but there's
one piece of advice I can give a
starting sound designer record
everything you can it takes months if
not a year to do the sound for a game
the best time for something could be
just at a moment's notice you have to be
ready